[Music]
morning my name did you think whoa
and I host the video series on YouTube
called AI adventures where we explore
the art science and tools of machine
learning I wanted to bring a little
piece of that here today in person so
let's go on an AI adventure together for
the purposes of this session let's start
with just a short definition of machine
learning and use that to build up kind
of a workflow and get into the tools
well then use that today to help us see
how we can solve machine learning
problems and see how we can use that to
apply to your problems outside of IO and
so we'll say that machine learning is
programming with data and we'll use that
data to create a system or model which
is trained to do some tasks and we train
this model there importantly using data
and so everything comes back to the data
so that's really the first step of
machine learning gathering your data it
all centers and starts from there next
there's typically some kind of
preparation needed of that data the raw
data is often not so suitable for use
and so we need to prepare it a little
before it's ready for your machine
learning third we'll need to choose a
model we want to use then train it up
and evaluate its performance do some
fine-tuning and finally make those
predictions do those tasks so we'll go
through each of these seven steps in
detail over the course of this session
so first let's see what question we are
trying to use our model to address in
the first place we'll walk through kind
of a simple example data set and go
through these seven steps using the task
to categorize some data about animals
okay we're going to say what kind of
animal is this based on some input data
is it a bird is it a mammal that a
reptile fish or amphibian a bug or an
invertebrate one of these seven types
and will be based on a variety of
different kind of stats about a given
animal so our model will take in this
data this structured data and use that
to try to make a prediction one of these
seven types of animals now that we know
what kind of situation we're modeling
let's dive into each of these steps in
more detail first up is gathering data
just because we know what problem we are
trying to solve for it doesn't always
mean that we have the data needed to
solve it and without data your model is
going nowhere so ask yourself this where
does my data live and in what format and
how can I get to it
these are oftentimes the early stumbling
blocks as we try to use data to solve
and address our problems and perhaps
you're actually in a situation where you
don't have all the data you need you
need to collect your own data this is
also a common use case and you can get
creative in solving this problem by
building some systems for data
collection
perhaps you make it a game one really
interesting example of this is quick
draw quick draw is an online game that
lets you draw a specific picture and
tries to predict what you were drawing
so it tells you draw a basketball or
draw a boat and you know it's it's kind
of fun people like it and as a result
the game has generated over 1 billion
doodles of hand drawn images from around
the world and this data set is open
sourced on github and there's actually
an AI adventures episode that we just
put out if you want to learn more about
using this data set and playing with
that but back to our step
we've gathered our data what's next well
we got to prepare that data data
preparation could be its own separate
talk entirely so we'll just touch on a
few aspects here exploring your data
before we do any kind of machine
learning can really help you understand
your data better and this is fundamental
because it gives you this intuition
about your data set and can save you a
ton of time and headache later on in the
process and so I really encourage folks
to clean their data to look at the data
and kind of get some intuition about it
helps you identify gaps and you'll learn
a lot about what you're working with
along the way and maybe you'll find that
you actually need more data or that
certain piece of data you collected
weren't actually so useful after all one
tool I like to play with to do this is
called facets we'll take a little brief
detour and talk about that facets is an
open source data visualization tool from
Google research and it can help you give
a better get a better sense of your data
distribution and yes there are lots of
tools that enable you to do very similar
things you can write out commands and
call functions but this one kind of puts
it all in one place and because it's a
UI you won't forget to compute a
particular statistic or look into some
corner of the data because it's all
computed for you it just shows up and so
you can just kind of browse it and so
here we can see facet to apply to our
data set of these animals from the zoo
and most of them are kind of ones and
zeros data sets of does it breathe does
it have a tail does I have feathers
things like that and so that's why we
see this kind of funny distribution on 0
to 1 but a lot of times with numerical
distributions you'll see something far
more interesting now let's move on to
our third step of machine learning
choosing a model and we'll discuss a
little bit about model selection how me
we might go about doing this
using the least effort possible and for
first let's build an intuition around
what is happening when a machine
learning model is working well
so here we see how the model is trying
to divide up a region or we're trying to
say which side is blue which that is
hard to match the data which are the
dots so it's not the hardest example in
the world right everything's already
kind of separated forever so separate it
out but let's look at something a little
more interesting here we see the model
struggle for a little bit as it tries to
find a way to draw that enclosing circle
around the blue dots and it's really
neat to see that these tools are
available to you today which are
sophisticated enough to handle all of
the minutiae for you so you don't really
need to worry about the details of how
it's getting about it it's just a matter
of is it achieving the task but it is
fun to see and different models can
model different kinds of data and
different degrees of complexity so
that's what model selection is really
about it's about seeing what model is
the right fit for your particular data
set and the particular problem you're
trying to solve
now concretely what we're gonna do is
use tensorflow
to achieve this right so there's lots of
talks about tensorflow here at i/o this
year so I won't rehash those bits but
we'll see an example perhaps of what it
might look like to use tensorflow to
kind of do model selection - to actually
write that code especially if you
haven't had too much hands-on experience
with tensorflow this may be kind of a
useful look at just how accessible it
can be so this is an example of a linear
classifier it's similar to the first
animation we saw it's good for kind of
drawing a linear Deline between two kind
of spaces and we can see that it's
pretty straightforward but what if we
had more complex data right this one
line call well it kind of stays a
one-line call when you try to try it out
on a different model so we're gonna
replace this with a deep neural network
but it and it only takes a few small
tweaks and in this case we just have to
add one additional argument called
hidden units this defines the structure
of our network in this case we have
three layers with 30 20 and 10 neurons
in them and so all we needed to do is
just changed the name just replace that
text and add one argument you don't have
to replumb your entire system you don't
have to delete everything and start from
scratch so that's really neat and it's
similar for other models you can try a
lot of them just involve one flip of the
model of the method call and you can
basically play around with these
different menu of choices and so in that
paradigm it allows you to not have to
commit to a model kind of beforehand you
can try one out see how it does and then
come back so these seven steps you know
you've worked through it and you can
iterate back you can always go back and
cycle through and so that brings us to
our next step we've gathered our data
we've prepared it we've chosen a model
for now at least and now we can do the
training training gets a lot of
attention because in some ways that's
where the magic happens but in practice
it's often very straightforward you just
let it run and you wait so let's take a
look at what happens during the training
and then we can see it in code
conceptually when training a model we
pass in our data and we ask the model
right away to try to make a prediction
but the prediction will be pretty bad
because our model is initialized
randomly but we make this prediction and
we take it and compare it to the true
answer the correct answer that we know
and we use that information to update
the model and so each time we go through
and update the model with a new piece of
data as it works its way through the
training set it allows the model to get
better and better over time with each
training loop and so that's kind of what
the training process looks like
but in practice when you actually need
to code it up we take our function we've
created the model and we just call dot
train on it it's literally one line you
just need to provide a function that
gives it the training data inputs and
that's it it's one line and so once the
training completes you run this function
you go off and
you grab a sandwich and you come back
and it's time to do evaluation we got to
evaluate our model it's to see how
accurate it is see if it's doing a good
job of performing its primary task so we
can show it some examples of things that
we know the correct answer is - and the
model did not see those questions in
training it didn't see that data in
training so we use this evaluation data
that we set aside to measure the
performance of our model and
conceptually it looks very similar to
training right it's still this the same
shape but the important difference is
that there's no arrow at the top it's
not a closed loop the model does not get
updated once we check its prediction
results and so if we did update the
model then it would be no different than
training and we'd be essentially
cheating right so the evaluation data is
kind of precious in that way we don't
use it to update the model we hold it
aside and we reserve it for evaluating
the performance of our model in code
it's just as simple as everything else
we've seen we just call dot evaluate you
want to evaluate you call dot evaluate
and notice that we are passing in
evaluation data right I would say eval
input function so it's not a training
data and if we were using the training
data let's say we copied that line down
we just swapped out train for evaluate
and we forgot to change the data source
now we're evaluating the performance of
our model using the training data and
that would be a big mistake because the
model has optimized itself for the
training data and so if you evaluate
using that same data what happens is you
misrepresent the true performance of
your model and it will likely perform
poorly on real-world data once you
deploy it since it's never seen and you
never measured how it does with
previously unseen data so this brings us
to our next point how can we actually
improve our model then with
the training we did the thing we ran the
evaluation now what do we run training
some more how can we tweak it further we
could always swap out for a new model
but what if we decided on this model but
we want to improve it as is this is
where hyper parameter tuning comes in
these models have parameters of their
own but what values should we use and
how do we pick them much like how you
can try out different models you can
also try out lots of different model
parameters this process called hyper
parameter tuning in some ways still
remains a active area of research but
that doesn't mean that you can't take
advantage of it conceptually you would
take our training and instead of just
training one model will tweak that model
and create a couple of different
variants and so we'll run training on
different variants of the same
underlying model but with different
model parameters and see how that
effects our accuracy so we'll train and
evaluate all of these different variants
of the same or similar models and then
see which one performs best that's how
it informs our parameter choice but you
see a lot of that is experimental you
got to try them to see what works so you
might have to break out your for loop
and so yeah the task of choosing good
hyper parameters is something perhaps
you've intuited this you could probably
turn into a machine learning problem
itself right optimizing the parameters
for the model that you're using for
machine learning but we'll have to save
that for another talk all right so we've
gathered a data we've prepared it chosen
a model and trained it evaluated the
data and we tuned the hyper parameters
at long last we have reached her last
step making those predictions this is
the whole point of training up the model
in the first place right it wasn't just
to get a really good accuracy or to
create heat on our server it was to
actually do something useful with it and
so making predictions we take the model
and we deploy it somewhere or that's
isolate it out and we
show the models some data that it hasn't
been trained on and then see what kind
of outputs predicts and so that's our
seven steps right conceptual seven steps
of machine learning but let's see what
it actually looks like in practice right
we'll turn to the tooling side of the
things and look at what you use beyond
just tensorflow and how you might
actually achieve these seven steps so
we're gonna go and look at some code and
in particular well I'll feature a couple
of tools we'll get hands-on with and
I'll point you to some additional
resources as well first up is a tool
called code lab if you've ever worked
with any sort of notebook environment or
a repple on the web before this is
basically a way to run Python in the
browser but not just run Python it's a
whole notebook environment you can put
markdown the code actually executes and
because it's hosted essentially on
Google Drive you can share with other
people so let's switch over to the demo
and I can show you what it looks like to
use collab so here we see and I've
loaded up collab and we can run various
commands right all all the things that
we would expect so let's see we're still
connected and in collab because it's a
notebook environment you have to upload
your own files and it connects the
internet so you can also authenticate
and pull things down in my case I have
our data set loaded on the machine and
so we can download that and I've got
pandas loaded here so we can take a look
at our data set you know as promised
it's a bunch of animals and a bunch of
statistics and at the very end there is
a class type and so collab you know it
really lets you just execute the code on
the screen in well in real time and
moreover because it's all hosted on
Google Drive I don't have to spin up any
machines in the background it just works
seamlessly and you can put comments in
and share your work with others
and make huh there we go and do
collaborative research we're just work
in general so that's really neat and so
let's see I think we have some time so
let's actually walk through a little bit
of kind of water I've ended up doing
here we took tower data and what I'm
doing is shuffling it and then splitting
the data so we had a whole data set
right this this whole data set happens
to just be a hundred and one different
animals so it's probably the smallest
data set that I've probably come across
but you still need to do the same types
of best practices in this case I've
taken it and split it into training and
evaluation data because if I use all 101
to do training what am I gonna do to
evaluate my model so we'll split it in
this case I chose a fraction of 60% and
40% but that ratio can be adjusted and
so we can see we have our training data
all sixty values and then we have our
evaluation data below and I do a little
bit of pre-processing so this is the
processing your data bit and notably the
last column of the data set is the label
it is the answer one through seven of
what the correct type of animal it is
reptile amphibian mammal etc the problem
is the labels go from one to seven and I
need them to be zero through six in this
particular case so I just shifted by one
by subtracting one and and that's it so
pretty simple pre-processing I would
expect that a bigger data set perhaps
would do more things and so we can see
that our data apparently I didn't make
this run run always run your code and
our input function here is pretty
straightforward
it takes our raw data and if we want it
to be shuffled we can call shuffle on
our data set and I just let it repeat
and batch into chunks as needed and so
this will just feed right into
the training and believe there was a
talk about datasets specifically earlier
at i/o so if you missed that you can
catch the recording or roll back the
livestream so we have our data set our
input function and I think I forgot to
run this cell again and this is a little
cell I have here to just kind of try out
my input function to make sure it's
working always good to testings
and so we can see that my input function
is indeed returning all the data of each
types of the feathers whether it has
eggs where there's airborne does it have
a backbone things like that and so each
kind of these arrays represent a batch
of data and I was also playing around
with this to check out the unique values
for each column just to make sure like
most of them are ones and zeros but
there's a couple here that are a little
bit strange for example there are
animals with five legs apparently so not
all datasets are perfect and tensorflow
uses this notion of feature columns to
represent the incoming data models are
pretty generic and so by using feature
columns it allows you to customize it
for your particular data set in our case
I just loop over all the data all the
columns all seventeen of them which
happened to be numeric and set that as
numeric so it's really just a
configuration to let tense for the flow
know how many columns and of what type
are coming in so we'll run that and if
things break it's because I forgot to
run the cell so yell at me if that
happens and so here's that line that we
saw before right with the creating a
model so here we'll create a linear
classifier and pull in those feature
columns and say that there are seven
different classes seven different
possible values for the animals and I've
combined the train and eval they've
trained and evaluated calls into a
function just for convenience so that
they both run together I want to run the
training on the training data and I want
to run the evaluation on the evaluation
data so wrapping this together helps
make sure you don't introduce bugs as
you rerun cell
as you go along so let's say we run the
linear model and we just let that turn
and so this is all backed by Google
servers and apparently it is taking its
sweet time while it's doing that well
this one's done so we got 90 percent
which is like okay right there was only
100 rows we took 60 of them for training
and used 40 for evaluation so it's not
the most reliable metric the idea here
is that the tooling is there the code is
there you should replace this with your
own data which will be much better than
this data set and get awesome results so
as promised the deep neural network is
very similar it's literally the same as
before but I replace it with hidden
units
I guess there's one notable difference
is that I do take the old feature
columns that we had from before and we
wrap it in an indicator column so that's
just a space to put the linear networks
data into a way that the deep neural
network can represent so it's a little
bit out of scope for this talk but it's
an adjustment
just for deep neural networks and linear
networks don't have to deal with so
we'll let that get created whoops just
create a new cell so I guess that's also
a good thing to show off here so we can
very easily create you know code blocks
and cell blocks in between and you can
have all sorts of great editing kind of
abilities here and you can turn it into
markdown you execute the cell and it'll
it'll be there
so with the deep network I forget if I
ran this maybe we'll run it again we can
also in like push the model further
right the percentages here are sometimes
wonky because they are because there's
only 40 values in the evaluation data
this is effectively you know something
over 40 is getting it right and then the
other ones are wrong so in this case it
looks like that 10% probably about 4 are
wrong or 3 or 4 are incorrect so let's
make some predictions and and see what
got
tensorflow also has a dot predict
function just like it had trained and
evaluate and so you can pass in I just
took the evaluation data and sliced out
a couple of examples to take a look at
so we can see you know here that when we
do that you get you know the prediction
and the correct answer so in this case
those five that I arbitrarily chose
happen to work out but what if we wanted
to see the exact ones that we got wrong
so this was a little experiment I ran
just because I was curious now which
ones were the linear network getting
wrong and which ones were the deep
network getting wrong in this case
they're they're different right they got
the same number of incorrect predictions
they all had four wrong but they're
actually different examples and so this
would be an opportunity to dig in
further and play around with that the
one final thing I'll add here is that
collab or collab Tory has a GPU support
and so you can toggle on GPU so if you
have big datasets and big fancy models
and you want to access that sort of
stuff go and get that GPU and so let's
switch back to the slides briefly and
take a look at another tool aside from
collab there is another tool that we
have that's very similar it's also
notebook based and you might have heard
of it it's called Kegel
and while Kegel is most known for its
competitions or discussion forums and
datasets it also has a feature called
kernels and kernels is really just a
fancy name for notebook and the kernels
look something like this this might
start to look familiar from colab except
it's blue and kernels is different in a
couple of subtle ways firstly I want to
let's just switch over to the the demo
for keidel kernels and we'll see what
that looks like how was that so I took
the notebook that we had earlier in
collab and I downloaded the notebook
itself as a a Python notebook file and
since Kangol has datasets we we actually
have a
zoo animal classification data set how
convenient that I chose the exact data
set that already exists on cattle right
and so we can click new kernel and I'm
gonna choose notebook and Cal kernels
not only run in Python but you can also
choose to run them in our for those of
you who prefer a car and what I can do
is I can actually upload a notebook well
first I need to download that notebook
so let's do that
so from colab we will download this is
what I get for zooming in a lot download
the notebook and then once it's
downloaded we can upload that notebook
back into cattle kernels and so boom we
have that same notebook now in kernels
there's one small tweak because we had
to upload a file from the local drive
for collab we're gonna get rid of that
and the only other tweak is that in
Kaikohe kernels the data lives in one
directory up called input so if I run
the first cell and then we'll work our
way down we'll see that the data lives
in input and it's the same kind of thing
and since we already saw the rest of the
notebook it's literally the same thing
what is interesting though is that in
the kernels we can see let's give it a
name
and we can commit that notebook and what
catalano's does is it will run your
notebook in a new fresh environment
separate from the session that you're in
this will generate a notebook with all
of the outputs that we've been seeing in
a kind of nice view only format which is
really useful for sharing because what
if you want to share your notebook as
well as how it was executed to others
you want reproducible notebooks and so
that's kind of what we see here so we we
ran in the look it's done and we can
view that snapshot and so it's kind of
like a github model of like you can
commit versions of your notebook and so
by default your notebooks are private
and we can see here that things ran the
outputs are shown and I didn't have to
go through and run these one by one
right and if I ran these cells out of
order manually earlier to you of my
results running them top to bottom like
this will help catch those kinds of bugs
that would help would make it hard to
reproduce my performance down the road
when I come back to this next week or
next month and if you share your
notebooks you can then fork them you can
fork them you can also get others to
fork your notebooks as well as add
collaborators to your notebook so you
can add users to join you on the same
notebook rather than just forking them
so there's a lot of great collaboration
models across collab and tackled
depending on your particular use case
and I guess it would be good to also
just briefly mention that like collab we
can also enable GPUs in Kaggle kernels
as well so don't let that be a deciding
factor for you so that's Kegel kernels
let's switch back over to the slides and
talk about just a few other little kind
of tools and tips and tricks and before
we kind of wrap things up
and if we could switch back to the
slides awesome so let's say you don't
want notebooks let's say you tried
notebooks and they just weren't for you
or you have a bigger workload you need
to run a long-running job right it's got
to run for hours or you have a really
big data set and it doesn't fit in Kyle
kernels or it doesn't fit on your local
directory so you're not gonna upload it
to drive manually then you can use
something like cloud machine learning
engine where you can kick off a job to
run a long-running job that maybe runs
across a set of distributed machines all
of them potentially with GPUs attached
and once you're done you might want to
serve your model right you want to make
those predictions but perhaps you want
to do it at scale you're building an app
you train a model and you want to create
a rest endpoint that can serve
predictions to the world and so machine
learning engine also includes a auto
scaling prediction service you can
literally just take your tensor flow
model give it a name and be done
literally points of the file and give it
a name there's there aren't any other
steps because you can't do anything else
in terms of creating a model to serve
which is really neat and if you're
working with things like scikit-learn or
extra boost and you want to serve those
as well we'll take those too and so then
you don't have to deal with the ops
aspect of machine learning you can just
play with your data tweak your model
train it and deploy with ease and I
think most not most but many of you are
also perhaps aware of the machine
learning
api's that are also available these are
pre-trained api's for doing various
tasks they're a little more canned right
you don't provide your own data but it
does mean that everything just works out
of the box you need something you need a
picture to be turned into a description
you need audio to be turned into text it
just works
and so that's kind of nice but the
limitations of course are that you can't
customize it for your specific use case
that is still something real you'll have
to just wait up
a bit longer for would be one notable
exception of vision so the auto ml
vision is available right now in alpha
and so you can apply for that and supply
your own datasets to train and customize
your own vision API so that's kind of
like a neat side tangent the animations
that we saw earlier that I showed with
the orange and blue dots came from the
tensorflow playground so if you want to
play around with a neural network in
your browser and just like toggle things
on and off and just mess around head
over to playground tensorflow org and
you can do that right there
and don't worry you can't break it
it's just through browser you can only
break your own machine and so what's
next the code that we just saw is I made
it public it's on cattle so it's at
cattle calm slash youth Angie that /zu
demo if you want to learn more about
tensorflow
head on over to tensorflow org and
thirdly there's a machine learning crash
course that Google released recently and
so if you want to learn really dive into
the concepts of machine learning go
further than what we've talked about
here today head over there there's
basically a whole curriculum of videos
and kind of assignments that you can do
and really build up your machine
learning knowledge and finally if you're
interested in doing machine learning in
the cloud you can head over to the cloud
dome the white tent next to the Google
assistant dome and or head on over to
cloud.google.com
slash machine learning or /ml as I
mentioned at the beginning I host a
video series by the same name as this
session yeah I advise we explore some
interesting nugget in each episode about
machine learning and try to do some
hands-on demos once in a while and do
some interviews with interesting folks
so hopefully they'll check it out and
subscribe so I want to thank you for
joining me in this session and we really
you know I really appreciate you know
feedback on the session the information
so please head on over to the schedule
and you can log in and give some
feedback
so thanks a lot
[Applause]
[Music]
you